Here's the big one.
The 2014 Olympic slalom champion Mikaela Shiffrin…
…has already put that nightmare off 48 hours ago, the crash after the fifth gate.
No, it isn't, and she's gone again.
And Shiffrin,...
...same mistake as the giant slalom and about the same number of gates as well.
Four, five turns into the challenge, and the big favorite for the USA,...
...Mikaela Shiffrin, crashes out for a second time of asking…
…what was a shame two days ago is now a nightmare today,...
...serious psychological issues and problems for Shiffrin.
She cannot get those skis to work on this snow.
Wow, no words there, goodness me; poor, poor Shiffrin.
Very similar to the giant slalom.
First of all, how are you?
Right now, I've definitely been better, but…
…I've also been worse so, all in all, pretty medium.
We saw you sitting up there alone; what went through your mind?
I guess I just wanted to,…
…I don't know, take a pause and try to process or try to understand…
…what I really did wrong...
...not really on that turn, but just in general what I did wrong during the day…
…or during the weeks or during the years or whatever,…
…but when I had a mentality that I actually thought would be quite strong today,...
...it ended up being totally the opposite.